c'est tout le monde désolé c'est squeeze
je vais juste vous dire je peux pas
sortir la vidéo
jimmy l'abonné attend toute façon je
m'en fous tu me la beauté c'est de la
merde je j'en ai marre je voulais vous
dire voilà je suis malade donc
franchement ça me saoule et je déconne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et la monnaie c'est
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ok les gens sans rire voilà bah on y ait
dix mille abonnés c'est c'est quand même
un sacré palier qui est franchie moi je
fais les choufs les bordels donc
premièrement je tire a vraiment tous et
tous vous remercier pour tous vos
messages votre soutien vous êtes fidèles
vous m'avez encouragé vous êtes vraiment
top
et du coup j'ai voulu vous faire un truc
assez spécial pour ses 10000 abonnés
c'est à dire que j'ai voulu faire pas
n'est ce pas une seule vidéo comme celle
là aujourd'hui merci mont de couppes
heures j'ai voulu faire plein de vidéos
des trucs originaux du raca c'est
impossible d'ogeu c'est pas encore ça
dépend sur une bande de territoire mais
celui-ci vient on a déjà vu que j'étais
cassé spéciale
il s'agit d'un cas oui j'ai d'indiens
podcast ci porte sur je ne vous le
dirais pas encore divers et bien il y
aura aussi un rubis avec quartz est un
zombie avec style antique et arman sur
fifa contre elle jette ses cartes
cachées pour l'instant qu'il aura
obligatoirement dans toutes ses vidéos
parce qu'à l'heure où je fais cette
vidéo il faut savoir qu'il n'est pas
encore d'humeur abri
c'est d'ailleurs assez stressant de dire
ça alors je ne les ai pas encore qui
peut toujours le faire à qui ou quoi que
ce soit c'est tout non sans rire je
voulais vraiment tous vous remercier
c'est pour cela que je pense super zoom
sur ma bouche
ok c'est dégueulasse
en tout cas franchement je vous aime à
partir de maintenant un petit menu va
s'afficher vous allez pouvoir choisir
quelle vidéo voix et donc je vous invite
à cliquer sur celle qu on voulait de
toute façon les mines s'affichera à
chaque fois de vidéos donc vous aurez
juste la question c'est ce que vous
voulez voir mais je voulais voir si vous
êtes sur une vidéo que vous voulez la
revoir puisque vous aimez de la moi
c'est donc on se retrouve tout de suite
dans une de toutes ces vidéos
et puis et puis voilà on remercie tout
le monde à très bientôt en france alors
environ 30 secondes qui suivent des
graphismes étaient que cinq secondes de
cet entretien
dix huit sous-parties d'agression à tuer
tout le monde bye
[Musique]
oh